Hi, welcome back. Through all the
sessions in this class where we've
talked about different investment
philosophies, we've tended to focus on
financial assets, stocks, bonds, and
other traded assets. And in the process,
we've ignored what can be called
alternative investments. So, in this
session, I want to focus on that
alternative space. what we call
alternative investments, why we're drawn
to them, what is it that attracts, and
at least for this session talk about the
biggest of those alternative investment
classes, which is real estate. So, let's
get the show on the road. Almost every
investment book, every valuation book is
directed at people who are long only on
financial assets, stocks and bonds. What
does that mean? can buy stocks or you
can buy bonds but you you really don't
talk about the alternative to doing
that. In the process though as we said
we're ignoring vast swats of the
investment universe. What does that
include? It includes people who go short
on assets. It includes people who invest
in other asset classes real estate,
gold, collectibles, uh cryptos and
people who build their wealth by by
building up private businesses. These
ignored investment classes are what we
call alternative investments. In the
last two decades, they've been marketed
as a class to many investors who have
the bulk of their wealth in stocks and
bonds. But historically, they've been
held by only a small subset of
investors. Now, let's face it, there are
people who become wealthy by putting
their money in these alternative
investments. And it behooves us to talk
about this as an investment philosophy,
a philosophy of focusing on these
alternative investments and building
your wealth through them. So let's get
the show on the road. Much of
traditional investing and much of what
we learn about portfolio theory as I
said was directed towards people who are
long only on financial assets. What are
we missing when we do that? Three
groupings. The first is on the long
short axis that people instead of buying
stocks might sell short on them.
Included in here of course are hedge
funds which we've already talked about
derivative investing and structured
products. The second the second grouping
we're missing is in the public private
dimension. Much of our focus is on
publicly traded assets. But what about
private businesses? Here again, venture
capital, which we've all talked about,
private equity and private credit come
into play. And then if you look at asset
class, there are a whole group of asset
classes or investment classes we don't
really look at. That includes non-traded
real estate, collectibles, gold,
artwork, NFTs, which are the non-f
fungeible tokens, which became part of
the crypto growth over the last 15
years, and cryptos themselves, Bitcoin,
Ethereum, etc.
Now, of course, when you look at what
makes them attractive, there are two
things that make them attractive to most
investors. Most of us, because we're so
focused on our holdings and long only
short stocks and bonds, find alternative
investments attractive because of their
low correlation. I put quotes around the
word low because sometimes the low might
be not quite true. It might not be low,
but we perceive low correlation. saying
so what adding them to a portfolio
composed mostly of stocks and bonds will
make that portfolio more efficient in
terms of delivering higher returns for
any given level of risk. The other is a
little more subtle. The perception at
least is there are some very smart
people in each of these spaces
especially in venture capital and
private equity where we assume that and
hedge funds where we assume that those
people are able to beat the market.
We'll talk about the logic of why we
think that is and therefore are better
in a better position to deliver alphas
in a world where traditional public
market investors have struggled.
Remember the sessions on active versus
passive investing. So we'll talk more
about the sales pitches but you can see
the missing pieces. Let's focus more on
each of these dimensions. Let's start
with long short. In principle there's
really no difference between a long and
a short position. And all you're doing
is reversing the cash flows in a long
position. You go buy something first,
buy shares, buy bonds. So the negative
cash flow happens first when you buy and
then you wait and sell later. So the
positive cash flow comes in when you
sell. In a short position, you reverse
the sequence. You sell short. So you
collect the cash flows up front. Then
you buy it back a year, two years later.
The negative cash flow comes later.
Mathematically, positive followed by
negative. negative followed by positive.
Either works as long as the positive
exceeds the negative, right? But in
practice, it's undeniable that
regulators and many investors view
selling short as very different than
going long from a moral standpoint and
investing standpoint. What do I mean by
moral standpoint? There's this
perception that if you sell short, you
must be a speculator that you really are
not interested in creating value over
long the long term. I don't understand
it but it is what it is. Many
institutional investors though are
restricted to be long only. We talked
about equity mutual funds. Equity mutual
funds for the most part have to be long
only. They can buy shares but they can't
sell short. For a century or so hedge
funds have carved out the special place
at least in US markets. They've been
allowed to be both long and and sell
short. Although many hedge funds don't
take advantage of the selling short and
it's undeniable that being able to sell
short changes the kinds of return
combinations you can offer investors.
Earlier on in this class we talked about
hedge funds often deliver lower returns
than traditional mutual funds but their
standard deviations
are so much lower that they deliver
better ratios of returns to risk. And
finally, if you look at the opening of
derivatives markets, which are
relatively recent, the last 50 years,
you've had options and futures markets
open open up. The the truth is
derivatives markets allow you to be
short on a on a stock without actually
selling short on the stock by doing
what? By buying a put option on a stock,
you're effectively selling short. So
long short, the much of what we've built
in investment theory comes out of being
long. But you can clearly see the
potential that you open up by being able
to sell short on things that you think
are overpriced. The second dimension is
public versus private. Again, much of
the focus in investing in valuation is
on publicly traded companies. But there
are lots of private businesses. They
need capital, too. If you're a young
private business, of course, you go to
venture capitalists to get this capital.
And we talked about what venture
capitalists do well and do badly in a in
in in an earlier session. We talked
about activist growth investing and the
returns that they offer. If you remember
that session, much of the payoff to
venture capital in terms of adding that
alpha has decreased over time, but
venture capital provides capital and
they presumably make a return on that
investment. for more established private
businesses which are larger you know
more mature private equity has been the
source of capital. So you got venture
capital, you got private equity. They
fall in the alternative investment
space. And then when you turn to
borrowing money, historically companies
borrowed money either from banks or in
the bond market. But in the last few
years, you had a private credit market
explode where investors pull their funds
to lend to private businesses rather
than invest in the equity. We'll talk
about the rationale for private credit,
what it does well and badly. But again,
you can see with venture capital,
private equity, and private credit, you
open the public private domain to more
investors. And finally, if you look at
asset classes, real estate in
particular, it's true there's a segment
of real estate that is traded. We'll
talk about that traded segment either as
real estate investment trusts or real
estate securities or in the bond market
as as mortgage back securities. But the
bulk of real estate for much of the 20th
century and spilling over into the 21st
century has remained in private hands.
Private hands either with owners holding
on to the real estate or people are
focused just on real estate investing.
Right? Then there's a there's a final
asset class that we'll that we'll call
collectibles. What are collectibles?
Collectibles, you know, have an array of
different investments. You can start
with gold. one of the longest standing
holdings that investors have had now
centuries. It's held its its its pricing
allure. It's a draw for some investors.
There are some people who have the bulk
of their portfolio in gold. You can have
artwork, you know, paintings, you know,
you can have digital art in the form of
nonfgeible tokens essentially where
you're betting on what'll happen to that
artwork over time. And at the risk of
getting some push back here, you could
argue that much of the crypto space
falls more into the more into the
collectibles column than into the
currency column.
There's an argument to be made that
Bitcoin is actually millennial gold. So
essentially with asset class, you can
see how much is left out with
traditional investing. Now in terms of
the sales pitch for alternatives, I kind
of mentioned it up front. I want to
reemphasize it. The biggest sales pitch
that people have used to sell investors
on alternative investments is they have
low correlation with their existing
holdings because your existing holdings
are mostly in traded stock and bonds.
We'll see if that's true in terms of the
numbers and whether you should trust
those numbers, but that's partly what
drove in the last two decades getting
endowment funds and big investment funds
to invest some of their money into
alternative investments. The other pitch
is the people who run these alternative
investments especially VCs, private
equity and hedge funds are the smartest
among us. There's this illusion or
perhaps delusion that there is smart
money and that this is smart money and
smart money is more likely to deliver
alphas. In a world where that's become
more difficult to deliver in public
equity markets, maybe you're looking
outside alternative investments might
deliver those alphas. So let's take a
look at this correlation matrix as it's
called to see what it teaches you as an
investor about the add-on value of an
alternative investment. Let's assume you
have all your money invested in an S&P
500 index fund. So let's go to the last
line. Adding bonds to your fund will
actually make your fund better in terms
of the risk return tradeoff because the
correlation between investment grade
bonds, so I'm talking about you know
corporate bonds is only 37. The scale
here is a correlation of one means you
have an investment group that works
moves entirely with whatever you're
holding. As correlation drop below one,
you're actually adding something that
has the potential to create a better
trade-off in terms of risk and return.
And the lower the correlation becomes
and remember correlations can go from
plus one to minus one, the more
efficient your risk return trade-off
looks like. So investment grade bonds
reason I mean they move with your stocks
most of the time but not by enough that
you don't get some benefit by adding
them adding cash and that's the
definition of something riskless has a
correlation of zero that's often why we
add cash is its value stays the same no
matter what happens to stocks but let's
take a look at hedge at first
international equities let's suppose you
have your money in the S&P 500 say look
what if I put my money in foreign stocks
50 years ago Oh, that was a good thing.
It actually had low correlation with the
S&P 500. Those days are done. The
correlation between international equity
and the S&P 500 is86. There's some
benefit, but it's marginal. What about
hedge funds? Hey, hedge funds have a
correlation of 72. That's pretty high.
It's not one. So, there's some benefit,
but relatively small. Adding currencies
or managed futures, much bigger
trade-off. So, this correlation matrix
by itself will shift over time. It'll
change depending on what we put in. But
here's the bottom line. The the big
pitch for alternative investments is
that their correlation is low or
negative. And adding them to your
portfolio will make your portfolio more
efficient in risk return. But you can
already see that that sales pitch is
stronger with some alternative
investments. Gold maybe uh you know
maybe some kinds of hedge funds but not
so strong with other kinds of pitches
you hear for alternative investments.
Now what about the alpha argument? We're
going to come back and talk more about
alphas in these individual cl you know
about as we look through time. But if
you look across the different
alternative investment classes here are
two realities that kick in. First is
there is some alpha at least on average
as you look across these investments.
Alpha is in terms of returns that look
higher than they should be given the
risk in these investments. But here's
the open question. Is that because we're
mismeasuring the risk in these
investments or is it because these
investments are actually managed by
people who deliver alphas? The other
thing that should come out to you when
you look at this graph is how much
divergence there is within each class.
Let's take private equity. The median
private equity fund at least in the
period that this particular graph was
constructed delivered a return of 6
1/2%. The 75th percentile was 7. The
25th percentile was 5 1/2%. But look at
the spread. There are funds out there
that deliver much lower and much higher
return. So within each of these classes,
you can see a big divergence. But the
median value tends to reflect this
tradeoff that you see. If you remember
our discussions of venture capital and
private equity,
remember what's happened to those alphas
that excess returns over time. They've
shrunk as these investment classes have
become bigger. So you can see the basis
for both the correlation and the alpha
argument. Now before we talk about
alternative investments as a grouping
and look at individual alternative
investments, I'm going to put in what I
think is something we all we need to
think about as investors. There are two
words we use in investing
interchangeably that we shouldn't. One
is the word value. The other is the word
price. We talked about this earlier in
the context of you know of an earlier
session on value valuing something
versus pricing something. But to value
something you estimate the expected cash
flows and you estimate what you would
pay for those cash flows given the risk
in those cash flows. So let's say you
know stocks they can be valued based on
expected cash flows risk and you come up
with the with the present value but they
can also be priced by looking at other
stocks like the stock we're trying to
price and using know scaling the price
to something that they share in common
earnings book value and then saying my
stock is cheap or expensive given what
people are paying for other stocks just
like mine. Assets have cash flows they
can be both valued and price. So you can
value a stock or you can price the
stock. You can value a bond or price the
bond. You can value a private business
or price the private business.
What about commodities? Commodities are
things we use to produce
something else, right? Iron ore is a
commodity by itself. You know what are
you going to do with iron ore? You can
value it at some macro sense by looking
at the demand and supply for iron ore,
but that's messy and it's not really
useful. For the most part, we price
things like iron ore or oil against what
the own their own history. You can say
$50 per barrel is cheap because for the
last 25 years the price has ranged from
45 to 90 and 50 looks at the bottom end
of the range. Commodities can be valued
in a macro sense, but they're often
priced. What about currencies?
Currencies can't be valued. If you ask
me what is the value of a dollar, I have
no idea. But I can price the dollar
against other currencies. That's what an
exchange rate is. And if you're a good
currency, a currency that maintains
value, low inflation and greater
acceptance. I can use it all over the
world, you should trade at a higher
price against a currency which has much
more loss in value over time because it
has high inflation or it's not accepted
around the world. Currencies can only be
priced. As for collectibles, they cannot
be valued. And here's why. When you buy
gold, what are your cash flows? There
are none.
If you don't have cash flows, you can't
value something, but you can price it.
We'll talk about pricing gold, but you
got to price it against something that
you think is a competitor for your
money. So, currencies and collectibles
can only be priced. Commodities mostly
are only priced. Assets can be both
valued and priced. You're saying, "So
what?" Let's take some alternative
investments and talk about whether they
can be priced,
valued,
or maybe only one of the two apply.
Let's take real estate. If you buy
commercial real estate, a rental
property, you have cash flows, right?
The rental income. You can value real
estate, but you can also price real
estate against what? Against other
buildings that look just like yours on a
square foot basis. If you have
residential real estate, you could
implicitly estimate a rental income, but
it's mostly priced. Real estate for the
most part is a pricing game, but you can
value it, especially with commercial
real estate.
Collectibles can only be priced.
Artwork, gold,
and there's a third group of
alternatives that I'm going to talk a
little bit about called trophy assets.
What's a trophy asset? A trophy asset
has cash flows. You can value it as an
asset, but because it's a trophy, people
value it for other reasons, the pricing
is completely disconnected from the
value. So, you can get a value, but you
compare the value to what people are
paying, there is no relationship, and
there's no convergence.
Now, as as an advanced notice on trophy
assets, I'm going to argue that sporting
franchises, especially in the
high-profile sports, the NFL, the Major
League Baseball, the NBA, the basketball
in the US, Major League Soccer, you
know, but outside the US with soccer,
Premier League in the UK, IPL, Indian
cricket teams when you get trophy
assets. Why? Because the people buying
them are not interested in buying
businesses. They're buying a trophy. And
when you're buying a trophy, you price
it. So even though there might be a cash
flow effect that can be valued, the
pricing dominates.
As I said, this session I want to talk
about real estate, the most the biggest
alternative investment class because I
think we need to give it more attention.
Some real estate is traded in the US.
I've actually categorized the traded
component of real estate. REITs, real
estate, investment trust, development
real estate. So these are publicly
traded companies either do development
are diversified in real estate or have
real estate operations but they're a
tiny fraction of the market. They're
only about 4.15%
of the market cap. Real estate traded
real estate is out there but it's a tiny
segment. In fact if you go global that
4.15% becomes even smaller on a global
basis. Even less real estate is traded
than even in the US. You think so what?
There's a huge chunk of real estate that
is not rated. It's estimated the start
of 2024 about $400 trillion in real
estate around the world in residential
and commercial real estate which makes
it a much bigger market than public
equity but much of it is not traded.
Now why do people buy real estate? If
you're buying it as an investment,
you're buying it for the returns, right?
And if you're buying it for the returns,
the question is what are the what do the
returns look like on real estate versus
public equity or the bond market. Let's
compare it to, you know, stocks and
bonds because those are the traditional
investments made. With stocks, the way
we measure returns is we look at traded
stocks, the S&P 500, or with bonds, we
look at traded bonds. We can compute the
arithmetic, the average return, a
standard deviation. So these are the
numbers we tend to you to be able to
look up easily. So on traded
investments, stocks, T-bonds, T bills
and corporate bonds, you can look at
publicly traded indices and compute
their returns and standard deviations.
You can do this with traded real estate
as well. And many people when they come
up with returns for real estate look at
the traded portion, real estate
investment trust. But remember when you
looked at the previous W this is a tiny
segment of real estate. In the last two
decades we've had indices that try to
measure the returns on non-traded real
estate. The case and Schiller for
instance have a very widely used index
of residential real estate. And here's
the challenge you face with both
commercial real estate and residential
real estate that's not traded. Remember
you need a price to get returns. You got
to come up with an estimated price. The
way Case and Schill have come up with
the estimated price is look at
transactions on similar real estate.
Your property might not have been sold
or bought, but since a property near it
has been sold or bought, use those
transaction prices on the on the traded
on the on the portions that were bought
or sold to update the index. So that's
one of the caveats. These returns are
not as reliable because they don't come
from daytoday hour to hour prices. is
they come from these transaction prices.
And if you look at the returns on
non-traded real estate, they don't look
that great. I mean, in fact, if you
look, especially at residential real
estate, it looks that you'd have made a
4.42% return, which is less than the
return you'd have made on T-Bonds. But
here's the caveat. These are transaction
prices.
You look at the change in price. You
know what you're missing is if you had
actually bought this residential real
estate and rented it out, you'd have a
rental income. So presumably this 4.42%
captures only the price appreciation
part of real estate. And then you add on
the rental income. That could may bring
it up to to at least on par with
commercial real estate. So
price appreciation in general in real
estate has been pretty modest over the
last century, four to 5%. If you add on
the cash flow, you get to about 8 or 9%.
It's again not mind-blowing, but the
standard deviation in returns you're
also going to get from looking at these
appraised real estate values is going to
be low. Not because real estate is not
risky, but because you don't have traded
prices. You're looking at these
transaction prices. So that low standard
deviation might be a delusion because if
that non-traded real estate was actually
bought and sold on a minute-by-minute
basis, who knows what the standard
deviation would be, but as a class real
estate has not been a standout in either
direction. It's not hugely impressive
returns, but it's got returns that match
up to many publicly traded assets. And
the question is, how much of it should
you hold in your portfolio? Now, your
bigger pitch for real estate might be
not that its returns are higher than on
stocks and bonds, but that by adding
real estate to your portfolio, you make
your portfolio deliver a better
trade-off. Why? Because real estate
historically has not been highly
correlated
with traditional traded assets. Let's
suppose, let's say you took, you know,
your residential house and you took the
S&P 500 and this is a study that looked
at cove movement over a long period. the
correlation between your the value of
your home and the value of the S&P 500
is minus.13 which means historically
putting some of your wealth in a
residential house was good was was a
good investment decision because even
though it might appreciate only 3 or
four or 5% a year by adding it to a
portfolio composed of stocks and bonds
you made your overall wealth more
stable. That was the push between
getting people to buy their own home and
in fact extending beyond that into real
estate. You can see that with other
components of real estate. The
correlation with publicly traded assets
historically has been either low or
negative. And the pitch for adding real
estate to your portfolio came from that
negative correlation. When I did my MBA
in the early 80s, this was a big pitch
you heard in investment classes. should
add real estate to your portfolio
because it has either has a low
correlation with stocks or a negative
correlation. We'll talk later about how
that correlation might have shifted over
time, but that's really the pitch. Now,
one of the ways you can see this this
low correlation payout that's not
abstract is by looking at the returns
you make across different investment
classes in different time periods. In
this table for instance, I've looked at
the returns by decade that you'd have
made on stocks, on T- bills, on T-
bonds, on corporate bonds, and then I
add gold and real estate to the mix.
Now, we'll talk more about gold in the
next one, but at least you have the
introductory table here. And then I look
at the returns by decade. I'll talk a
little bit about why I have no returns
for gold all the way through 1969 when I
talk about gold. But let's take real
estate, right? If you look at the
returns in real estate between 1930 and
39, it's a big you look at that return.
So why would I invest in real estate?
I'd have made 6.19% on an annual base in
stocks, 2.91% in T- boost, 5.93% in Tond
only 87%.
In fact, in most decades, the return on
real estate lagged
the return on financial assets.
But then you get to the 1970s and you
can see the benefit of adding real
estate and we we'll talk about gold more
as I said in a future session is real
estate held its value in the 70s when
the other financial assets melted down.
You can already see that this negative
correlation we're talking about
essentially means that real estate can
hold its value under some some
macroeconomic conditions that are not
good for financial assets. So the low
correlation is just the entree to
thinking about why adding an investment
class is good for you is in some periods
where macro risk damages your financial
assets having an alternative investment
might allow your wealth to kind of hold
up. So with that long lead in what the
20th century taught us about real
estate, let's see how real estate as an
investment class has changed over the
last few decades. In this graph I have
pictures of risk premiums in different
markets. If you remember ear in an
earlier session we talked about equity
risk premium. This is the price of risk
in the equity market capturing the the
the push and pull between greed and
fear. The second the second number that
you see there is a BA rated spread which
is basically the spread in the bond
market between a BAA rated bond and the
T-bond a measure of risk uh risk
premiums in the bond market. And then
you have two numbers specific to the
real estate market. One is called a cap
rate. You're saying, "What's a cap
rate?" It's a rate that real estate
investors use to price real estate
properties. Here's how it works. Let's
say your cap rate is 10%. And you have a
rental property that makes a million
dollars. You will be pricing that
property at 10 million. You're saying,
"How do you go from the million dollar
in rental income to the 10 million?"
Remember the cap rate was 10%, you
divide the rental income by 0.1, the
10%. you get $10 million. In a rough
sense, it's a measure of the expected
return that real estate developers bring
to the game. And if you subtract out the
risk-free rate from that, you come up
with a risk premium for real estate.
That's a green line. Already, you can
see in the 1980s, there's something
weird going on, right? You're getting a
negative risk premium. You're saying
that basically means you're settling for
less than the risk-free rate. You might
wonder why why would I do that? Remember
that that table with negative
correlation between real estate and
other financial assets, especially in
the 70s. If you're adding something with
negative correlation, you're buying
insurance. Key word is buying insurance.
And how do I make you pay? By accepting
a return less than the risk-free rate.
So the 1980s reflects real estate
standing in the 20th century as a
hedging investment class. And then
things seem to change starting in the
late 80s going into the 90s and clearly
into this century. The risk premium in
real estate is starting to look like the
risk premium in equity and the risk
premium in bonds. You're saying, "So
what?" Remember the old days, you own
stocks, you own bonds, and you owned
your own house, real estate. You had a
bad year in stocks and bonds, your real
estate held its value. So you your
wealth was pretty intact. That's no
longer true in this century. You have a
good year in stocks. You have good year
in bonds. You have a good year in real
estate. You your house went up in price.
You have a bad year in stocks and a bad
year in bonds. And then you look at your
property and
real estate seems to be seems to be
losing its hedging value. What might be
causing it? Lots of factors. But I think
one significant factor was that starting
in the 80s, we start to securize real
estate with the best of intent, right?
We wanted to make it liquid and
tradable. In many ways, we succeeded at
least on a subsegment of real estate,
mortgage back securities, real estate
investment trusts.
Something seems to happen when you
securitize an investment class. As you
securize it, it starts to behave like
stocks and bonds. In the process of
securitizing real estate, making it more
liquid and tradable, we might have
removed some of its of its hedging
properties. So if you ask me to compare
real estate as it was to real estate it
is today, here's how I contrast it. In
the 20th century, for the bulk of the
20th century, real estate was largely
untraded and illquid. It was held by
either individual investors as their
personal properties or as specialized
real estate investors. What does that
mean? They invested only in real estate
or mostly in real estate. High leverage
seem to be part of the real estate game.
you borrowed 80 90% of a property to
buy. The returns were low to moderate
but the risk also looked low whether it
was perceived or true yet low standard
deviations. As you saw in an earlier
table, real estate tend to move off in
in the opposite direction as your as
financial assets and it did seem to
offer inflation protection at least for
that one decade 1970s where we're
exposed to inflation. What has the 21st
century brought? Real estate is more
liquid and traded. That's a good news.
The investor base is starting to shift.
Institutional investors have entered the
real estate market now not just in the
form of adding REITs and real estate
traded securities to the portfolios in
the form of private equity investors
entering into actually holding physical
real estate. Black Rockck
was one of the biggest real estate
holders in the country right now.
Leverage has stayed high and we'll ask
whether that's sensible because real
estate prices have become more volatile.
And the biggest shift is instead of
being negatively correlated, real estate
seems to be moving more with financial
assets. What does this all mean? It
means that if you're adding real estate
because you thought it was hedging your
portfolio, that hedging property has
weakened. And if that is true, the
expected returns in real estate would
need to go up to compensate for the fact
that you now have a riskier asset. On
the inflation protection front, the jury
is to luck. We don't know whether real
estate has lost its inflation
protection, but we will see. Now, as an
investor, you might say, "What does this
all mean? Should I have real estate in
my portfolio?" There are three ways you
can play the real estate add-on or or
investment in your portfolio. The first
is you can make it an add-on. If you're
primarily invested in financial assets,
you add real estate to your portfolio
hoping for some hedging properties. As I
said, that's weakened. So, I'm not sure
it's doing the same service that it did,
but don't expect miracles from that real
estate investment. It might not match up
to your financial asset in the long
term, but you're doing it to as
insurance or hedging. You could make it
the center of your portfolio as an
investor. You could have the bulk of
your wealth invested in real estate as
real estate developers had in the last
century. Many of them became immensely
wealthy. It's true. They were wealthy,
then they went bankrupt, they were
wealthy again. It was a boom and bust
business. But what did they build their
wealth on? Localized knowledge. What I
mean by localized knowledge is they knew
the cities that they invested in. New
York, San Diego, not just in terms of
geography and what the premium locations
were, but in terms of navigating the
rules and the regulations that govern
real estate because those can be a
labyrinth for somebody who doesn't know
the process. So if you want to make real
estate the center of your portfolio, you
need to find a differential advantage,
information advantage you can exploit.
Or you can trade real estate. The swings
in real estate have become greater in
the 21st century. And if you're a good
trader and you call you can call the
shifts in momentum in real estate, you
can tra trade real estate. So you've got
to make your choice based on what you
think you can bring to the table. So
what's the bottom line? It is true
traditional investing is focused too
much I think on the standard paradigm.
What's the standard paradigm? You you
buy stocks, you buy bonds. Key word is
buy. You're long on stocks and bonds and
financial assets and everything else
gets short shipped. In this session,
hopefully I've at least opened the door
to alternatives. Now, couple of those
those doors that we opened, we had
already opened the long short phenomenon
when we talked about hedge funds and
private businesses when we talked about
private equity. But this session has
primarily been focused on one of those
alternatives, the largest in my view of
those alternative investments, which is
non-traded real estate. The sales pitch
for all of these alternatives is built
on two premises. One is low correlation
with financial assets and you saw with
real estate that shifts over time and
the potential for alpha way to make
excess returns presumably in some of
these alternative investment classes.
So I hope you found the session useful
and I thank you very much for listening.